I didn't know Sir Philip was gonna be
here the man thank you thank you to
Glamour for being supportive to me in
all fields I had an incredibly exciting
year and a half I started this company
and when you start a company obviously
it comes the core of it comes from
something that you're passionate about
for me that would be to be active to
have support to set goals that are
actually attainable and to be surrounded
by women and to be empowered and to
create communities of women so I thought
to myself what what is the thing that I
could do where I could incorporate my
love of athleticism dance spinning being
active and fashion and of having a voice
I said I'm gonna start a line of clothes
that I'm actually going to wear every
day and I'm going to hopefully create a
community where women who can't afford
the things that most of us can afford in
this room can be a part of that
community which was the most important
thing for me and it succeeded and it was
actually one of the most rewarding
things I've ever been a part of so this
is more exciting than then I could have
ever thought which is that you have a
vision for something and you watch it
come to fruition and obviously when you
start a company and as Philip said we
now have hundreds of employees and are
gone global and continue to expand
exponentially and I just couldn't do
that without an incredible team of
people and 15 design team and partners
that are doing a lot of the heavy
lifting but this is taking a lot of my
life right
but I love it it's fun and and and I get
to express myself differently and it
doesn't get to take me away from my day
job and and and and I have to say Amy
you said somewhere you you said so I met
my mom you know for me I grew up with an
incredibly ambitious mother but her
ambition was for a greater purpose as
she sort of stepped out to say I'm going
to become the first female producer
making my movies you know she she in in
true Goldy mama form
she really was doing that for all women
that's what I grew up watching and when
people say you know what what is it that
you how do you want to utilize your
celebrity which is my least favorite
word on the planet but how do you want
to utilize this and I really for me it's
it it's what my mother gave to me just
being able to watch which is setting
setting up setting platforms for women
to actually realize that we we are all
here together and need to continuously
support each other no matter what the
judgment needs to go all of the things
that we have been programmed to believe
as women need to be thrown out of the
window and we need to actually create a
support system that will Mabel we are
are more powerful together than we could
ever be alone and so for me in this
little fabletics community that's really
at the core of what I want to create so
glamour thank you and thank you guys and
this was a great night